hi i'm rebecca essence congratulations
on your big win this evening thank you
thank you
um this has been like a really big a
couple of months a year for you the book
you know you're producing bel air and
now you've gotten your first ever sag
award what is this if you want to call
it a second act like what does this feel
like for you right now
you know it is a uh a beautiful time in
my life the the the combination of
working
on uh king richard and the work i had to
do as an actor uh i was doing it while i
was working on the book
so i was mining
my childhood i was uh
you know really trying to understand my
relationship with my father
as i was trying to understand richard
williams and then my parenting with my
kids so it was a
it's been a time of deep
uh personal reflection and it is
resulting in an artistic comprehension
um and a growth as a man
uh growth as an artist that i've never
had this kind of growth spurt in my life
beautiful answer thank you thank you
thank you
the next question will be coming from
kate at access hollywood
okay bill congratulations on this
i will congratulations on this well
deserved award you had said that richard
williams sometimes had to
may cross the line to make the
impossible possible do you feel that
that applies to you as well
yeah you know i i definitely think that
there is
a
a certain amount
of
it maybe even
naivete
there's a certain amount
of
of you know i hate to call it insanity
but you know you have to believe
something that's not yet true
right so
there's a and you have to believe it
powerfully even though it doesn't exist
and even though the the universe hasn't
opened the door for the thing to enter
the world yet and you have to believe it
fully so
you know this is a thought universe and
the the power of those thoughts the
squid game must go on something else um
this is a this is a thought universe so
i think it's it's really critical to be
able to dream
wildly even if it's not something that
people
view as realistic
you got a little emotional
oh they cut you off oh
sorry
we have uh
all right bye-bye thank you
yeah let's see that's the thing with the
virtual press conference they just they
just shut you off
okay
oh wait yo they unmuted me
there you go
you got you got emotional in your speech
i wanted to ask what was going through
your mind in that exact moment and if
you saw your friend denzel giving you a
standing o yes yes you know it's um
you know the journey we've been on it's
like
in this business working
working with children
you know young people
um
this business can be so
brutal
and
you know many times i've seen young
people's
um
spirit broken by the brutality of this
business and i took it as such a
personal
endeavor to make sure that sanaya and
and demi
and you know all the girls and and even
anjanu i took the
the
richard williams
perspective of protector and just
watching their faces on this journey um
i just i just got overwhelmed with the
the joy of being blessed enough to
escort them
to the doors of this profession
thank you very much all right thank you
thank you thank you
you